[Music]
all right welcome back it's the time
you've all been waiting for it is time
for
jeopardy warm up we have our guests here
our contestants we have denise valdez
ted florendo
and brian lopez now truth be told i did
not come up with this
that ted is hot so it's not his voice
this is not a sports question it's a
real
real hard question and whoever gets that
should be not only the jeopardy king for
the
for the day but for like the next week
here we go okay
all right this giant sea monster was the
size of a submarine and it is nevada's
official state fossil go
oh you got 15 seconds um
ted you're wrong denise you are probably
wrong and now brian's wrong
time
we're out of time sorry nobody got it
sorry it's
each it's a forest oh we got a minute
like you said it's 15.
oh well what the
it was take a bunch of coffee slugs
yeah the bigger question is who doesn't
know this chris go back to the sports
office there you go
three of us do not know that yes okay so
yeah slow down i have a question for you
why did we rush that so much oh you know
why
because it might in my ear christmas
seconds
hey have a good night see you back at 11
facebook twitter goodnight everybody